we're gonna do a new thing here see if
it works essentially the topic of this
Q&A is how to investors measure startups
or something like that and so what I did
was I posted I don't know if you saw but
I posted in the forum and asked for a
bunch of questions there are hundreds of
them and so I'm going to take the ones
that were uploaded a lot and then go
from there so most of this is going to
be me asking a new questions since Anu
has been an investor for a long while
she told me I will help answer questions
too but I just get started so the bigger
you kind of went over this earlier but
the big areas in which an investor
evaluates a start-up is team metrics
which you went over just recently in the
in the lecture unique insight and how
big the opportunity is are there any
other areas in which big areas in which
you evaluate yeah no I think especially
at this stage you're in and probably for
a while even your CDs a/b it all comes
down to only three things team product
market fit market opportunity that's it
and so the stage you're in it really is
probably the heaviest weight is the team
and so when it comes to the team it's
more about why are you working in this
idea right and what unique insight do
you have your clarity of thought on how
you plan to you know see this as a big
opportunity and how good are you at
convincing that like that's and if and
if an investor gives you capital do you
know what to do with it right so that's
that's pretty much it
so in terms of team what if I don't have
experience in the thing that I'm
building like how our investor is going
to believe that I'm a legitimate person
to work on this yeah it it actually does
not matter to be honest I know I think
pretty much if your consumer b2b
enterprise it doesn't we're probably
industry or domain experience helps a
little bit is really health care and bio
I think in FinTech there is slight bias
maybe because building a FinTech product
requires some domain knowledge or at
least interest and curiosity because
there's a lot of regulatory and
compliance but largely now so which is
why I said your clarity of thought
during your pitch to investors is what
matters how much you have thought about
it and how well are you able to
articulate all the nitty-gritty details
of your business you know is is what
matters and more importantly than not
you should always assume you are
teaching the investor about this space
and the company don't assume they know
it and so they they measure by how well
you are teaching them so that's really
the measure so one of the things that
investors say a lot is we want a team
that moves fast so how do they know
you're moving fast yeah well this is
advice C 2 we say that we have to move
really fast well if you have if you've
said that I plan to work on this idea
I've been thinking about it for the last
12 months and I plan to you know hire
someone and launch product in the next
12 months that's clearly moving slow
right so it's how they move how they're
measuring whether you move fastest how
scrappy you are heavy launched your MVP
how many iterations are you doing how
are things moving in the pace like and
at this point it should move really fast
I kind of week by week basis what are
you yes if you're working on something
people want there's a lot of light and
demand and so you should be able to find
users easily in fact if you don't know
your first I think what we say this a
lot but if you don't know your first 10
10 users 10 to 50 users it's potentially
there's no founder market fit there if
you don't know or to even find them and
one of the things relates to this one of
the things on the YC application if you
a lot of people apply more than once and
get in and one of the things we do look
at is there's a questions like something
along the lines of what progress have
you made since the last application and
we read that actually like well that's
one of the first things I read is what
are the learnings even if you don't have
that many users yet it's so what are the
learnings even you've made okay
local versus remote do you discount
remote teams or how do you evaluate
local versus reality um well I think
this really varies depending on who you
ask but I think one thing is clear which
is remote is increasingly taking off and
so it would be a ramus for anyone to say
oh we only focus on local and no longer
remote right
I think tools like slack zoom have
really made it incredible for more and
more teams to function I mean look at
get LaVon off ycs companies completely
remote zapier and other amazing company
completely remote so we don't make any
differences but it really comes down to
the investors selection I think it even
from an investor standpoint there's no
ding on whether it's remote or local
it's more that they're spending their
time but again here I do emphasize don't
do things to satisfy investor bill the
company you want if you build a great
company with lots of users from ver ever
the investors are they'll come alright
so this question is I ever constantly
that investors are investing in team not
product which we have said how does a
solo founder of fact into this like what
is like the team is one person so how do
you evaluate that that one person more
often than not it's the CEO that's
talking to the investor anyway we don't
recommend that all founders that are
tending all investor meetings because
obviously it's a lot of time you know
that comes on doing investor meetings
was as you have real work to do
so it really comes down to the CEOs
clarity of thought you know and how well
they are able to impress upon investor
by the way this is not just to impress
investors the reason why this clarity of
thought I keep bringing this up if you
don't have that how are you gonna hire
your first ten people if you can't
convince your first ten people that
you're building something big and they
should join you in your mission then
it's really hard to convince investors
right and that's why investors are
looking for that storytelling ability so
solo founder doesn't matter it's the
CEOs job the CEO really needs to be good
at it and they should learn and they
should you learn to be good at it do you
have any advice on how to know the
clarity of like the clarity floppies
like how are you doing well on that yeah
so this is probably a really high bar
example but I'll say that which is the
Breck's wanders and we can't patrol it
was the second time they were building a
company says they knew that they needed
to do this I don't know if they did this
and their first time probably not but
when they were going through YC they
actually literally iterated from a VR
startup idea to
Breck's right which was corporate credit
cards and they had built FinTech in the
past but both of them knew the stakes
were high at least for them because they
were dropping out of Stanford they
literally came out of Brazil to attend
Stanford they were dropping out at the
University and so they both wanted to
make sure that Bracks had a big
opportunity and before hiding a single
person they wrote down very clearly what
Breck's could be with all the products
that they could build in the roadmap
tested it but not like it was not a huge
survey but they just wrote it down to
really understand built a financial
model and week actually attended at the
accounting class in Stanford because he
had no idea how to build it and he built
a whole model year by year tested the
assumptions of market demand and what
penetration they would need ahead for it
to be at least a billion dollar company
and only of they after they both got
comfortable that there is a part and
this is what coding Stanford for and
putting our entire life probably for the
next 10-15 years on this they hired the
first employee that's is an amazing
clarity of thought right you are not
saying everybody should be there but you
should at least do the first exercise
what is if you were to convince someone
to join you who and you know more often
than not at this stage whoever you want
doesn't want to join you so what is that
compelling story call this one next
one's about international founder so
you've personally invested tons of money
in the international startups how did
those founders convince you to put that
money into their company when you're not
you're not from there like Columbia UK
all these other places yeah and I think
this is where you know I know I feel
like I'm repeating myself but it comes
to those three things and yeah it also
comes I think the international ones we
did were probably a little later stage
two so given we didn't have presence in
the region and we didn't know what was
really market demand we waited for some
more progress right so you see that in
metrics you see that in their thinking
you see that in a more fleshed out
process but even there if it's hard to
hire in San Francisco think about how
hard it is to hire there like there are
no exacts available with scale
experience so those CEOs actually have
to work ten times harder to have that
clarity of thought and to convince
someone from the US to move there
any suggestions of how to convince
someone start doing really really well
and if you do really well for example in
LA dam rappy basically convinced a few
execs they actually have done a
phenomenal job of attracting execs from
the US is you have you know the execs
felt they have it's the first time in
their life they have an opportunity to
make an impact in Latin like the way
they never did and you can do that
through a start-up it's really hard to
do in any other setting and so they've
been able to convince execs with Latin
connection obviously but have been
living in US and UK for many years to
move back and lead teens for the purpose
of applying oh I see we take founders
from everywhere and like Anu said it's
more about more about team and idea then
metrics or where you're from and stuff
like that okay so is bootstrapping us as
a solo founder an instant know in your
mind do you have advice for solo
founders so 10% batch from last batch
we're still a founder so we definitely
accept silicon owners as a at YC in
terms of what you guys do like is that
that no I don't think that's a great but
I would say this having you know
obviously observed a lot of my
co-founders even the ones at scale it's
such a hard journey and there are so
many things that are gonna go wrong that
having another co-founder generally have
seen has helped a lot more because
there's someone who can give a lot more
context than everyone depending on the
CEO but if you don't have that that's
fine but then by the be they're looking
for some senior execs at least one or
two who are incredible that you can lean
on for some portion of your business
because if it's still all you the main
challenge after the BBC is the CEO is
not scaling and so if you're a solo
founder just becomes harder if you don't
scale yeah it's always good I find that
the good solo founders build a community
around them of people to help them go
through some tough times should I
fundraise so maybe this is more
fundamental question of how do I what
are the indicators that I should see
before I take on investment even go
start fundraise you know most companies
tend to fundraise so but the short
answer is I actually always refer to P
G's post here because I love that post
which is try to be default alive and
raise as much money as possible as
little money as possible sorry
as little money as possible so you
remain focused I think it is super
important and it's lost you know on many
people but if you look at the really
even successful companies everyone has
done mistakes but they'll all say the
most painful time of their company's
life even in later rounds was when they
you know you may have more money in the
bank and you end up hiring more and then
you actually delivered a lot less so
it's not that your problems magically go
away your problems become tenfold
because your people problems
a lot more people problems so at this
stage especially I'd say the erase as
little money as possible and focus now
there is a question as to whether should
you raise or not right very few
companies don't race but zapier for
example never raised after I seed Emily
and I think because the business is so
good it's growing really well they are a
but a positive they have very healthy
margins and you know often weight would
tell me this like I don't know what to
do with my money in the bank why will I
raise more it's a great reason not
raised right but if you are not in that
luxurious situation then you know there
is something to be said about I need
capital to grow not necessarily for paid
marketing don't please don't think this
as paid marketing this is another common
mistake but more like I need a hire more
engineers I need to hire ahead of time
to build the things that I need because
I know I have a business model at the
end of it so therefore the way to think
of fundraisers if you think you are you
you have a clear path to the next
milestone and you may need like you know
maybe two hundred five hundred or one
million dollars then just raise that
minimum amount but come up with that
plan very clearly what is the money you
need to hit that next next milestone and
just raise that money because guess what
your dilution matters is perfect answer
have a plan basically okay so the next
set of questions there are a lot of
questions on basically how do I
fundraise without users are revenue
which is like a thinly veiled way of
saying how do i trick investors I think
into funding me when I don't know if I'm
building something I want but I will ask
these questions okay
how our pre-launch start-ups measured
specifically those that are low
commission but require a high user
volume again this comes down to the
founder but I honestly would say if you
really think that is a big company to be
middle to like why haven't you launched
and why haven't I shown some traction
before you go race because you can
easily especially today you can raise a
few hundred thousand dollars even from
friends and family and launch a company
so you should do that don't like you
know Joan guard pitching to investors on
some grand idea that you don't have a
plan
it is possible these days but I don't
recommend it I think if you have found a
credibility which is you're a second
time founder or a third time founder it
is easier to do those things without
launching but remember the if the less
traction you have and the less data you
show the smaller cap the smaller your
valuation the larger your dilution so
make sure that you really know that you
want to build a company that is worth it
and you believe that and so raise
accordingly because money will be there
if you execute right and if you you also
see that you you have enough use
attraction and there is something to be
built so I would say try to test it out
there are many ways to test it out these
days in low cost effective ways so do
that first before you know what is the
best way to show some traction when
looking for investment without launching
so like email lists user all these users
less wait list stuff like that there you
know this is the YC advice we give in
the batch which is if you don't have
money in the bank you haven't raced so
you don't have if you have users on
email lists you don't have users all
right there there are some like
obviously we keep telling you guys users
in revenue or the if that's your primary
metric revenue being like 99 percent of
you should just use revenue that way you
get cash in the bank and that's your
best type of investment they're all
leading indicators to getting into
revenue but the end of the day it's like
that's the only that's really the only
way all right
how do investors view non-biting
indications of interest slash support
and evaluating traction of the b2b
company so I'm guessing like non
non-binding LOI Zoar letters of support
for grant applications stuff like that
even matter not much if you have
traction and you have certain loi
spending then fine then they would call
those allies and ask what's the
probability of converting but at the
stage you're in if you go in saying I
have to otherwise it means no it doesn't
mean much yeah and then how does an
investor judge a heavy MVP that is
someone with basically a long sales
cycle so a health IT company it takes
four to six months like you need maybe
you need to raise money before you get
your first contract how do you show
progress yeah this is very true for even
enterprise infrastructure which is why I
made the point that you may have only
one or two customers at the end of 24
months that's okay most of these
companies try to do pilots so I usually
tell you know start with a pilot because
the companies also probably hesitant to
sign a you know 500k 1 million dollar
contract with startup so start with like
a four week six week pilot show progress
through that investors like to see that
they'll talk to that one or two
customers so if you are in the business
of selling large contracts like greater
than 500k ACB you know you can plan to X
have only like two to three customers in
the first 12 to 24 months because a lot
of your time is gonna go into making
sure that it's really successful with
that one or two customers so it's not
necessarily customer growth it's more
that one customer and how you're facing
with them all right so the last sort of
questions is on interacting with
investors all right so how do you avoid
investors when they say it's too early
for us what is the best way to handle
this how do you avoid getting responses
like that it is one of the most common
things I don't think you can avoid it I
think you know I would take the know and
not leading to the know and keep moving
here the know and move on is it sensible
to start engaging with potential
investors prior to finding product
market fit or should you just wait until
you have real attraction yeah at this
stage I would say focus on building the
product focus on getting your first
hundred users and then you know meet
with angels what do you agree
how do you find the perfect investors so
this person started with 30,000 on
AngelList and removed all the removed a
bunch of or had a bunch of filters and
then has like a thousand left how do
they pick from the thousand investors I
wish we had a answer for that or like
good I think it's basically you contact
all of them I mean it's like a sale if
you think about a fund raising it's
basically the same thing as a sales game
you have leads you have conversion you
have to follow up you have to send
personal messages I would just use
whatever spreadsheets you're using for
your sales game for this and just go for
that yeah I would say try to avoid the
investors that you don't have confidence
and not about the founders are
referenced that but if that's that's the
only rule of thumb but otherwise you
have to do exactly like whatever man
shouldn't like go through it like a
sales pipeline yeah this one's great for
you what are the best approaches for
minority female founders to gain
visibility with NPCs I think the
industry is changing a lot so therefore
it should be easier than it was before
I always had problems with the warm
intro because most pcs say you need a
woman to and I'm like okay as a female
founder you probably know less than 1%
of the people who know the VCS because
they're all males and it's really hard
to get a woman true right
I think that it's changing a lot there
are lots of you know first of all almost
VC firms are appointing female investors
so it's easier to get there's groups
like all raise that really help female
founders to get in front of meeseeks but
this is a common advice I give
irrespective of whether you're from a
minority represented group or not the
best referrals is through existing
portfolio founders period there is no
compensation for that so if you can find
an existing portfolio founder of that
firm and they he or she is you know
knows you quite well and is willing to
rough for you that's the best offer
in fact investors often ask their
portfolios for portfolio company
founders who should I meet with and
that's like one of their primary yeah
channels okay two more questions one
well actually just one more question
which was like a common one how do
investors come up with the valuations
yes I you know when I first started and
we see and actually before oh I see I
thought there was a lot of science to it
but it's actually art it's not science
so the truth is until you're about CDC
or so there is no science to it so it
literally comes down to what's the stage
you're at and what ownership does the VC
want so this is why if you have no
attraction someone might say I want 30%
of your company right it's not very
common in the US but it's very common
internationally and so you end up
raising 1 million at 30 you know point 1
divided by 0.3 literally that's your
valuation and so the you know I would
say if you're in the u.s. at seed it
could vary anywhere from 10 to 15
percent depending on the traction CDs a
is 25 percent ownership so if you're
raising ten million ten divided by 0.25
is the valuation if your CDs be it's ten
percent ownership so if you're raising
30 million 30 divided by 0.1 zero is the
valuation so that's why it's art there's
no science to it science really kicks in
after the sea because your growth stage
and you have a lot more numbers plus at
that point the growth investor is really
evaluating you as to what when can you
go public and what would be the
valuation that you go public and so the
valuation from the CDC's back calculated
based on that so it sounds like two
things dilution to target and supply and
demand so if you're a hot company you
can say I'm only going to sell 10
percent incorrect so here's my valuation
or if you're not then exactly the
investors yes
calculate that for you all right so
that's it three questions yes right
there
of course look at lambda school another
wise support for that company of ours so
I think it's important that I think
historically investors probably
struggled with education startups
because they found it tough to scale
right and if you don't scale that is a
cap at which it stops order plateaus and
I think with new tools like slack and
zoom especially lambda school has been
able to scale really well and also the
newer edit tech start up some more
outcome-focused so I do expect a lot
more startups in that deck yeah so the
question is how much revenue or usage
should I have before I go reach out to
investors so I'm not sure that that's a
I think it's basically running the
company is not to go get an investor
Yeah right so that's just the whole
premise of the question is the problem
that I have right is is like what do I
have to do to get this guy to like me
right and the whole thing it is like
you're going to an investor because
you're like man I need some I figured
something out and I need some money to
make this grow a lot faster I'm a little
impatient or I'm like god I figured out
a bunch of stuff if I just had this
stuff I would be able to make this a
whole lot bigger a whole lot faster and
I'm willing to give up equity to do it
right so sometimes you can be like hey
look I know more money would help me
grow faster but I'm not willing to give
up the equity and so that'd be a reason
not to fundraise so it's legitimate but
it is not what is my target the whole
question is do you have something
working so well and you've figured out
something that like oh an investor
will go like oh I should get on top of
this now from an investor's point of
view when I'm trying to figure out is
like oh do does this founder or this
company know what to do with the
money I'm gonna give give him I don't
mean like hey what are the things you're
gonna spend the money on right I'm
always thinking about things in terms of
like my money being multiplied just as
like me as the general investor and so
I'm trying to just figure out it's like
I put this into this machine this little
startup machine and then what is it
going to be turned into what am I gonna
buy ROI and that's what the way your
pitch should sort of go so it says like
oh you know what I figured out this plan
if I raise a million dollars that will
get me to this target it's going to get
me to an additional it'll get me to a
$1,000,000 for example ARR right so you
might be at the early stage I want to
raise the million dollars that will get
me to this target and so to me ideally
that target should also be the point
where it will allow you to raise the
next round of funding that's sometimes
the way people think about it I don't
like people to think about it too much
that way because I always want you to
think about every round of funding as as
it as if it's your last you should treat
it as such but for the most part is like
oh that would be the most convincing
thing it's like this will buy these
results it gets my coming into this
stage and therefore you will imagine
that at the valuation that you are
buying into this company you will now be
able to imagine be worth a whole lot
more as a result so you are fundraising
when one you need the money to grow to
you're willing to give up the equity to
grow number three you clearly know what
is the milestone that this will get your
company now what you might be able to
say is like the way we know that will
get us to a milestone because that will
well spend this much on product we know
that we have to get this much sales and
we're going to have this percentage to
play around with a bunch of
experimentation to see if we can get the
product market fit I think the other
thing is you need to have confidence
like don't take people's money it's not
I think some founders these days mix it
up with it's free money or it's just
like it's money and if it disappears
it's gonna be totally okay like it's
other people's money don't take it
unless you feel confident in yourself
that you can grow this business and in
most cases like having users and revenue
already and it's growing at some pace is
like good evidence yeah right here
[Music]
so the question is what what do people
consider when they're in the early stage
a common factors to consider an
accelerator or was he or I take a jewel
investor I think that the basics of the
question is like you know there's a
certain stage of the company dictate
whether I go straight to like raising
from angels or I should like go to an
accelerator or an incubator and so
that's a there's a complex answer to
that because at YC we have a whole race
everyone from like having a bad idea is
a good but a good team and no traction
that we fund do people who already have
millions of dollars in revenue will do
YC core and usually you almost always it
is like if you're before series a YC is
going to be helpful to you that being
said we have had a handful of the series
a and post series a companies do YC
batch there's two joint and be a part of
the community the question I think has
to do with like if you need money you
probably should not be picky like
someone's hundred thousand dollars as
good as someone else's a hundred
thousand dollars
and so for you if you're just like man I
really need this to like work on this
full-time or like get to the next
milestone then like you should not be
like which one should I choose from my
list of all my options right I don't
think you should think about that it's
like the only people who will take you
as an accelerator an incubator in the
Saskatchewan then like god bless you
you're doing what it's necessary to like
make your passion and dream happen I
have no judgments against that like and
if you become really great as a result
of it then that's like that's my problem
I didn't figure out how to found you or
like accept you when you applied to our
program
so that so that's number one is like
money's for the most part money
especially at the seed stage second
choosing which one we're good for use up
to you and so like I can't speak for any
other programs so I have no idea how you
know some other programs sort of
compares but a lot of people will do
incubators just because for us they're
like oh my god I have a company the
reasons why people like to do YC is like
I have a company that I like if I join
that community I could really sell into
or I could take advantage of that sort
of network that would be really
wonderful that's number one number two
is just like man I want to raise a ton
of money and you might want to pick yc2
to do that because we have this demo
date that works really really incredibly
and those people who participate in are
definitely tends to get a whole lot
better deal again I always think like
there's no reason why any company should
not apply to I see if you're thinking
about raising money just because it's
absolutely free to apply and you have
nothing to lose and we don't knock you
for applying multiple times because
we're only trying to figure out what are
the reasons to fun you not reasons not
define you well I don't know the
question is that aren't switching
business models like you're starting
with transaction but then you may have
to monetize with advertising and that's
what it takes to build a billion dollar
company I mean as I think it's the more
important thing is articulating your
clarity of thought around it and so
you're just saying like hey we've built
this product this is our initial user
base for them we are doing transaction
you should know very clearly when you're
switching because you seem to know that
at least you are you asked this question
before so saying that but this is what
it takes for me to switch that and I
need X scale to get there and that's a
fine enough pitch but I think it's an
investor they're gonna look at what is
today and what are you doing today that
was that's how they look at it
[Music]
so I think the question is I've got some
pre-sales or I've sold some stuff I need
an extra X thousand dollars to get to my
next stage of growth should I give up
some percentage of my company to do that
well kind of like when a new said I
would rate like I would have planned so
I need to raise X amount of dollars and
I can get to this next milestone and
just raise that maybe you have a little
bit of a buffer like a one or two month
buffer for the burn that you're going to
experience but other than that like
don't raise don't raise a ton more than
you you otherwise don't want to because
you will be diluted and delusion in the
early rounds is it's gonna be circled us
too much dialouge in there Allianz will
make it a struggle with us to raise down
the road that's its supplying a man
right like that's not that's if you go
to investors you can ask for 5% but this
is I mean you got you just got it it's a
negotiation right
that's not a I'm definitely going to do
this it's whether they'll take it or not
I think this might be in the case of
like it's seed right like just like
twenty thirty thousand dollars is what
you need to get to get it finished okay
so for that small amount I actually
would advise you to try to get more
sales can I get more customers who are
willing to who actually say like I want
this enough that I'm willing to pay for
it to have it sort of built so that's
that's usually device I'd have it seems
to me for that little money I've seen
companies like maxed out credit cards
try to do small business loan etc it
doesn't seem to me for building the MVP
that you need
give up significant equity if it's that
small amount that would be my personal
recommendation to you like as an
investor's like of course I'll be like
if I think what you're doing is
promising I will give you money for
equity but again on your end if there's
any way that you can get to launch
without that it puts you in the most
favorable position when you negotiate it
later on the other thing about it is P
G's written an article I say talking
about how fundraising should be done as
a mode and what that means is like
fundraising is so distracting and so
time consuming because it's basically a
whole business model it's like you doing
b2b enterprise sales like asking for
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
people and so it's it's it takes a such
a long period of time it's so much
effort that it will distract away from
your company and so when you do
fundraising you should really only do it
when you really need the money and that
when you can dedicate time to it or like
you're able to dedicate time to it
without it's sacrificing the growth of
the company that's like the ideal thing
and then immediately turn it off when
it's done like time box set and get back
to work and so you don't want to be kind
of like what you see a lot of nonprofits
do words like I'm perpetually in a
fundraising mode I'm half like doing
we're on a product and also trying to
also collect money at the same time it's
such like a division and multitasking
that is so like not favorable to your
company and so I prefer not to be like
oh I do a little bit piecemeal here and
a piecemeal here an old piecemeal here
number one if you especially if you're
doing on a pre money safe you will not
be able to track your dilutions very
well unless you're like being diligent
about it it's a little bit easier if
you're using our default post money safe
but like again it's not an ideal for
your productivity and like growth for
your company to like dip at the
fundraising just when you need it
alright last question yes there's a lot
of noise but I like the framework that
you sort of observe the metrics through
are there other things that we should be
looking at for
stammers to see if they're going to be
growing with us from the sort of nine
business models yeah I think if you are
serve you know if your primary customer
has other growth state startups the only
metric that would track whether you're
growing with them is the cohorts right
so when you look at user attention or
dollar attention I mean this is what
stripe did right this is what checker
did another YC company that sells to
uber and other write chatting businesses
they grew as the startup screw so the
only way you measure that is through
your cohort I want to kind of make it
clear and put this all into a framework
because you just saw a bunch of extra
metrics to also track and you're like oh
in the third school program weekly
update it's only asked me for like one
thing and so how do I wrestle these two
contrary ideas together and the way
you're gonna do it is like there's only
one number that matters that gonna
dictate the health of your company and
so we've said it for 99% of you it
should be revenue and for a very small
percentage it'll be something like
engagement because it's a prerequisite
for you getting revenue so advertising
model is a good one for that these other
metrics that anna has talked about it's
really about it's like what are the
other things that are also probably
correlated with success of the company
but also numbers that you should know
yourself based on your business model
then an investor is probably going to
want to know about there are things that
will help you sound knowledgeable about
your business there's the stuff that
we're going to want you to know cold
that's how we sort of evaluate founders
like I love founders that know their
numbers whenever someone is like I don't
know or I have to look something up etc
it lets me know that as a founder
they're not constantly thinking about
their company and they're not a mastery
of all the sort of variables that
dictates their growth or their progress
so these other metrics helps us see into
that and so don't get obsessed about
tracking all of them etc addition like
if you have the opportunity you have
that business model it's gonna be really
great when you go into talking investors
that's the stuff that you want to brush
up on and make sure you have down cold
but ultimately how much money is coming
into the bank
or how much people are really loving
your product on as frequent an active
cycle as possible is going to be the
best indicators for the truth of is my
company doing well
etc okay this weekend adore and I are in
Chicago so we'll see all you guys out
there next week there will be not a meet
up but there is going to be able lecture
on Wednesday thank you so much we will
mingle and I'll see you guys next week
[Applause]
[Music]
you